[Music]
we are doing this that time but for the
first time we are not wow I don't even
know what that movie is right now no
one's asking me about what's oh I'm just
I need to know everything that there is
about Borg yeah yeah yes I do why that's
so cute
I was like man what if Jon waiter hates
no no no no no that cute that rodents
were they great the only thing standing
in front of the apocalypse
[Music]
is us you are a producer so why was that
important for you to get involved behind
the scenes as well I've always had the
the ambition to creatively be involved
in projects and behind the scenes and
and producing was the best way for me to
start I have massive ambition so I
decided to create my own company like a
room entertainment after Star Wars I
kind of reinvested into my creativity
and wanted to build and and collaborate
with the best in Hollywood to make you
know these producers are kind of like
the guardian angels of projects and each
angel does a different thing and so for
me within the realms of creative
collaboration I definitely felt at home
so it was very very important for me to
be a partner how did you feel when you
were named a sci-fi I can't but that
stuff is crazy I I personally feel I've
got a ways to go
I've just started and I'm finding my
feet even in terms of my craft as an act
I'm continually studying and improving
and I and I feel when I burnt it I'll
probably feel at peace but but for now
I'm just involved in this project so
that I really do appreciate it because I
I had to say that the support from the
fans has been amazing since I first
started out and thank you guys for
coming on to this journey now my new
endeavor with me yes a nice feeling of
course we're gonna talk about Star Wars
final question I got asked because JJ's
coming back for episode 9 what do you
say they couldn't stay away he couldn't
stay away i'ma go yeah jeez is it
because you missed me he was like yeah
it's cuz we all missed you
so yeah JJ's coming back and you don't
the weird thing about it feels like a
full circle in the same scene opened the
the movie Ryan is gonna shake up in a
crazy way and now he's about to enter
her and a time and a journey and Lee's
character so I'm excited for him get
some sleep JJ because you're about to
watch I was like he's the perfect person
to bring these characters full circle he
knows some more than ya
yeah and he started it so it's nice to
know that he's gonna finish this off
[Music]